[Musica]
data scientist information architect
gruppo hacker dp administrator
prepotenza manager community manager
influencer social media manager content
creator youtuber mi fermo qua altrimenti
mi prendete per pazzo questi sono solo
alcuni dei lavori che sono nati grazie
al web
quanti di questi dieci undici lavori voi
conoscete quanti pochi 12 al massimo
chissà veramente che cosa faccia un tp
administrator un gruppo hacker
chissà veramente che cosa faccia di
lavoro uno youtuber o un influencer io
oggi sono qui per proporvi un equazione
come quando eravamo al liceo è
un'equazione quindi va confutata oppure
va verificata l'equazione che voglio
proporvi è web uguale fallimento è vero
o falso
allora da quando esiste il web da quando
esiste internet noi ci siamo studiati
noi esistiamo effettivamente fuori dal
web for internet and daisy stiamo dentro
internet
ma siamo convinti che internet possa
essere lavoro possa essere il lavoro del
futuro oppure tutt'oggi siamo ancorati
all'idea che non ci possa essere la
realizzazione personale del lavoro su
internet purtroppo secondo me siamo
della seconda idea io
sette anni fa ho iniziato a caricare dei
video su youtube
l'ho fatto in modo completamente
spontaneo per nulla ponderato e quindi
questo è il primo valore da mettere
nella nostra equazione il web è
spontaneità la spontaneità e opportunità
l'opportunità il lavoro quando si parla
di web e di video in italia c'è sempre
un grande problema c'è un sacco di
confusione perché perché per il
palinsesto strutturato non si pensa al
web si pensa alla televisione
non c'è la televisione per le cose
ordinate fatte per bene però non si
considera una cosa veramente importante
il mercato e l'intrattenimento ormai su
piattaforme come youtube per esempio
hanno un rapporto molto molto stretto
milioni di persone ogni giorno solo in
italia con ogni età possibile
immaginabile sono spettatori di youtube
e dell'internet in generale non capendo
minimamente minimamente il mezzo che
hanno in mano
quindi la domanda è il web è fallimento
o il lavoro
ricordiamo questa nostra equazioni da
dover confutare o da dover verificare
mi spiego io ho iniziato appunto sette
anni fa su youtube mettendo le parrucche
effettivamente ho iniziato facendo dei
video veramente leggeri leggerissimi
volevo semplicemente intrattenere il
pubblico e divertirlo e qui viene quindi
un altro valore importante per la nostra
equazione cioè la leggerezza sul web
porta a un largo pubblico
però non mi bastava ho capito fin da
subito insieme ad altre persone che
potenzialmente sul web si poteva fare
qualcosa di più si poteva cambiare
qualcosa e si poteva lasciare un segno
vi sto parlando del 2011 e noi io ed
altre persone
abbiamo creato freaks freaks è una web
series che parla di supereroi a roma
totalmente gratuita e totalmente
disponibile su youtube
questo progetto è il successo di questo
progetto ci ha portato talmente tanti
iscritti talmente tanti giovani che si
riconoscevano nel messaggio della serie
che ci stimavano che ci avrebbe permesso
di cambiare veramente le cose
noi avremmo potuto allargare il pubblico
avremmo potuto creare un vero e proprio
manifesto perché freaks è stata una
sorta di punto di riferimento per quei
giovani che nonostante le brutture della
propria generazione appunto si volevano
sentire dei supereroi ed era bello ed
era bello per questo per noi e per le
persone che vedevano freaks dicevo
avremmo potuto allargare il pubblico
avremmo potuto creare un vero e proprio
manifesto generazionale che non esiste
per la mia generazione per la
generazione dei più giovani e avremo
quindi potuto consolidare l'universo in
cui
rifugiare il nostro pubblico non vi deve
sembrare in strada questa cosa perché
effettivamente ogni generazione ha avuto
e avrà sempre un luogo sicuro in cui
rifugiarsi
pensiamo per esempio alle radio
indipendenti degli anni 70 c'è un film
peraltro che vi consiglio che si chiama
i love radio rock che racconta
meravigliosamente secondo me quel
periodo e questo è questo concetto però
che succede abbiamo creato freaks freaks
è andata bene la prima stagione ha fatto
8 milioni di views su youtube e non ho
avuto nessun tipo di produzione di
sponsorizzazione
a parte i nostri canali e il nostro
passaparola però eravamo eccitati
eravamo inconsapevoli incoscienti di
quello che stava succedendo e
soprattutto dato molto importante il
sistema intorno a noi intorno a freaks e
il sistema internet non capiva
minimamente la potenzialità e la potenza
di fuoco di freaks e quindi il movimento
freaks il manifesto freaks non è esploso
quindi per il momento
l'equazione web fallimento funziona però
andando avanti io voglio una cosa non ho
guadagnato monetariamente da freaks
ho continuato attraverso quell'idea di
successo che era stata passato a me e ai
miei colleghi e al pubblico di freaks a
testare ho sperimentato senza una
struttura senza un ordine
continua a tirare fuori format
continuavo a dire cose senza avere un
pensiero preciso su quello che stessi
facendo e questa cosa ci ha portato al
vero primo fallimento e cioè la seconda
stagione di freaks e che cosa è successo
noi abbiamo investito c'è stato la
produzione che ha investito insieme a
noi nella seconda stagione di questa web
series che aveva fatto nel suo piccolo
la storia del web in italia ormai 67
anni fa ci siamo divertiti a farla
tantissimo e stata un'esperienza
incredibile un'esperienza che ci ha
lasciato veramente tanto come regista e
come autore ma anche come ragazzo di 23
anni che si è trovato in una situazione
molto più grande e bella di lui però non
ha funzionato non ha funzionato come la
prima come la prima stagione ma questo
caso vuol dire vuol dire che non si può
e non si poteva
secondo ora lavorare sul web che cosa
abbiamo sbagliato che che cos'è che non
ha funzionato e soprattutto la domanda
che voglio porre a me ea voi esiste in
questo caos che vi sto presentando sul
web
un elemento che possa confutare al cento
per cento l'equazione web uguale
fallimento sì esiste è l'identità che
cosa intendo
il web è un far west ancora di più del
mondo reale
devi essere molto bravo e questo è
importante a presentarti i primi secondi
sono essenziali sul web devi capire
subito dove vuoi arrivare
devi capire questo per riuscire ad
essere quello che vuoi avere un
obiettivo a lunga gittata è
importantissimo devi sapere il tuo
prossimo passo ma devi avere la visione
la vision come si dice nei prossimi
dieci passi che farai
ecco questo è il modo il primo modo per
combattere il fallimento sul sul web e
ovviamente questo però porta ad un
pensiero molto molto importante
freaks perché freaks quindi non ha
funzionato nella seconda stagione perché
non ci sono cinque stagioni di freaks
prodotte e disponibili sul web o in tv è
proprio questo il problema
vi dicevo prima non si pensa al web come
palinsesto ordinato si pensa solo la tv
quindi l'errore che noi abbiamo fatto è
stato quello di non trasmettere
interamente la seconda stagione di
freaks su youtube dove effettivamente il
pubblico aveva imparato a conoscerla ad
apprezzare dalla marra ma è stata
trasmessa in tv in televisione
questo che cosa comporta comporta che il
progetto non ha più un'identità chiara
il pubblico si divide si disperde non sa
dove andare a prendere la puntata da
vedere dove andare a prendere il
contenuto che stava che stava cercando
avevamo un messaggio importantissimo e
cioè che una generazione con delle
brutture poteva sentirsi una generazione
di supereroi e non abbiamo capito dove e
come comunicarlo non esiste vento
favorevole per il marinaio che non sa a
quale porto approdare queste seneca è un
filosofo autore politico
dell'antichità del primo secolo antichi
quindi un po di anni fa e forse leggendo
meglio seneca avremmo avuto una
soluzione in mano però siamo qui oggi a
parlare proprio di questo trailer
isernino experience e quindi il
fallimento che c'è stato grazie dico
grazie a freaks mi ha insegnato
personalmente a rilanciarmi sul web
quindi ho cominciato a riflettere su me
stesso a riflettere sulla mia identità e
ho capito esattamente cosa volessi
essere cosa volessi fare quindi ho dato
una svolta al mio canale piano piano ho
cominciato a non produrre più i video
leggerissimi le parodie e video con cui
le prime persone che avevano conosciuto
e le o sostituiti piano piano con dei
video più intensi più riflessivi sul
cinema perché perché io voglio fare il
regista sono regista e la regia la cosa
più bella che mi sia capitata davanti
gli occhi sotto mano nel cervello da
quando sono nato e questa è una cosa che
volevo comunicare al cento per cento
alle persone che mi seguivano quindi
avevo bisogno di comunicarlo sul mio
canale che cosa è successo
io ho annullato completamente i video
divertenti quasi del tutto anzi e ho
cominciato a punto a parlare di cinema
il pubblico
improvvisamente è calato della metà
quindi ho tolto la metà del pubblico dal
mio canale
questo è un fallimento assolutamente no
perché perché il pubblico che ho
individuato con i nuovi video era un
pubblico che era interessato la mia
comunicazione
qual è il segreto è il segreto è crearsi
un target crearsi un pubblico che parli
la tua stessa lingua
prendi qualcosa che ti piace prendi
qualcosa che possa piacere al tuo
pubblico e cerca di creare un linguaggio
nuovo un linguaggio sperimentale un
linguaggio personalizzato questo è
quello che bisogna fare
sul web trovando la propria identità e
quindi io stavo trovando la mia identità
ho trovato la mia identità da regista e
da comunicatore di immagini e molto
importante che io vi faccio un esempio
che vi fa capire la comunicazione web e
vi fa capire effettivamente cosa possa
funzionare o no
l'equazione è la stiamo confutando piano
piano quanti di voi
alzate la mano quanti
sono i gamer sanno che cos'è un gamer su
youtube alzate le mani
perfetto allora il gamer
facciamo finta che più fisiche non vedo
niente però perfetto il gamer è lo
youtuber che gioca ai videogiochi
ok perché i gamer stanno funzionando e
funzionano tantissimo perché avete visto
un video di un gamer o vostro figlio
vostro nipote vostra cucina vostro
fratello sorella ha visto un video di un
gamer perché loro riescono ad avere
un'identità precisa e specifica sul web
in sostanza se tu sai chi sei
sul web è bello e molto bello ed è utile
ma se tu parli con qualcuno che ti segue
che ti sostiene è questa persona senza
indugio riesce ad indovinare chi tu sia
e indovina appunto riesce a farcela
hai vinto hai fatto centro specialmente
sul web perché perché il web è luogo
dove noi tutti i giorni e questo lo
facciamo tutti quanti scrolliamo facce
informazioni musiche video mondi interi
attraverso i social network ci mettiamo
lì distrattamente a farci passare
davanti gli occhi tutti questi stimoli
di conseguenza se riesci ad acchiappare
un pubblico con la tua identità e se
riesce quindi a comunicare da subito
quello che tu sei costruendo un
linguaggio personale effettivamente hai
vinto qui vi dicono i gamer vi spiego
perché i gamer si rivolgono a un
pubblico molto giovane
la maggior parte dei gamer sono molto
giovani e questo già un elemento che
effettivamente ci fa capire un sacco di
cose il gamer parla la lingua degli
adolescenti empatizza con gli
adolescenti
qui le persone che non sono adolescenti
nemmeno io sono più adolescente non
impazziamo con gli adolescenti loro sì
perché perché parlano una lingua senza
freni una lingua urlata loro non devono
adattarsi a delle limitazioni per essere
apprezzati dal loro pubblico loro devono
semplicemente comunicare loro giocano il
loro pubblico si fida di loro lido
l'adrano perché lido la roma perchè loro
finiscono i giochi perché sorridono
perché si disperano perché
a volte dicono le parolacce e lo fanno
lo fanno
ed è questo anche un elemento di empatia
totale con loro pubblico
loro sono l'esempio più pratico e
diretto e puro di comunicazione riuscita
sul web facendo un attimo il punto
quindi abbiamo capito che la togliamo
all'equazione l'equazione era web quale
fallimento quindi si può confutare
queste quest'equazione secondo mese con
un mix di spontaneità direzione e
soprattutto identità
ovviamente per trovare la propria
identità e per individuare la propria
direzione bisogna sperimentare bisogna
provare bisogna fallire
ovviamente bisogna fallire e poi bisogna
ripartire questo è un ciclo virtuoso che
coinvolge tutti gli ambiti ma sul web
trova la sua estrema espressione perché
il web è esagerato ripeto è un far west
è un far west
ancora più del mondo reale il problema è
questo noi possiamo parlare di mille
lavori come vi ho presentato all'inizio
del web
sono parole che per voi possono contare
zero e in realtà non dicono niente
questi lavori però vivono costantemente
le persone che lavorano in quest'ambito
vivono costantemente con una grossa
paura del fallimento ed è una cosa molto
sbagliata perché in realtà per
contrastare questa paura del fallimento
e soprattutto per contrastare un mondo
che ancora non ha minimamente capito la
potenza di internet e non ha capito
minimamente che su internet si lavora si
guadagnano dei soldi dei soldi veri con
cui si comprano le cose appunto la
speranza è quella di contrastare questa
ignoranza questo blocco con la
consapevolezza del proprio lavoro con
l'identità e soprattutto con il
contenuto dobbiamo essere quindi bravi a
presentarci dobbiamo essere bravi ad
individuare una lingua comune e
sperimentale nostra e personalizzata ma
anche derivativa con il nostro pubblico
dobbiamo essere ricordati per ciò che
comunichiamo e soprattutto per come lo
comunichiamo questo e internet è un
luogo dove veramente in due secondi
qualcuno si dimentica di te e quindi
devi sempre trovare il modo di rimanere
sulla cresta dell'onda
andare in trending topics su un social
insomma bisogna stare sempre lì come si
fa creando di una fanbase che anche tra
dieci anni probabilmente potrà parlare
la tua stessa lingua perché la tua
lingua e la lingua che il loro parlano e
che a loro piace dicevo bisogna
comunicare bisogna sapere quello che si
sta comunicando e bisogna convincere le
persone con la propria comunicazione
perché la verità e secondo me questo è
il nocciolo della questione
avremo sempre bisogno di raccontare
qualcosa
questo lo penso da più profondo volendo
fare il regista ancora di più avremo
sempre bisogno di raccontare delle
storie avremo sempre questo bisogno
la cosa che dobbiamo fare adesso è re
imparare a farlo nel modo giusto
grazie
[Applauso]